. Let me ask you a question.
What do con men do, con men, con people?
What do scammers do?
Scammers come up with scams.
Donald Trump, despite losing the presidency,
is going to go out with one last scam on the
way out.
Donald Trump's campaign has started to send
fundraising emails, urgent fundraising emails
saying to supporters, donate to us to pay
for recounts, to pay for the legal fight,
to show that we really won, to pay for voter
fraud lawsuits.
But if you look at the fine print of those
emails asking for money, they say that anywhere
from 50 to 60 percent of your donation by
your I don't think anybody in my audience
is donating, but yours and Trump's donations,
50 to 60 percent of your donations meant to
fight the result and pay for recounts and
go to court, they actually will go to paying
off Trump's debt.
Debt is a major problem for Trump personally,
business wise and apparently campaign wise.
And one such fundraising email actually says
50 percent of each contribution to be designated
towards Trump's 20 20 general election account
for general election debt retirement until
such debt is retired.
Money beyond that will go to the recount account.
There is always a grift.
There is always a scam.
A separate Trump email went out asking for
money for the Trump Make America Great Again
committee.
And that one says, Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're
donating here in order to fight.
You know, we got to keep Trump, we got to
fight it.
But 60 percent of your money is going to go
to debt.
It's not actually clear how much debt Trump's
campaign has.
And in all seriousness, putting the campaign
debt grift aside for a moment.
Imagine being so gullible that you get conned
into donating money to get this billionaire
cash for what are completely bogus legal battles.
Like imagine that one hundred percent of the
money actually went to the legal battle as
opposed to only half of it.
That is also a con job.
There are plenty of people, including folks
on fixed incomes, who have been tricked by
this and they're donating their hard earned
money that they can't even really afford to
donate, thinking maybe my donation will get
Pennsylvania back for Trump, maybe my donation
will get Nevada back or Arizona back for the
mango madness.
Maybe Tangerine can take back some other state
and they can't even afford it.
And on top of the 50 to 60 percent of their
donations, that on top of the fact that 50
to 60 percent of their donations won't even
go to that.
They go merely to trying to help Trump pay
down debt.
And it actually raises real questions of,
you know, we've been saying Trump won't concede
because of his ego, because of his narcissism.
He's going to fight it and he's going to maybe
do rallies, demanding recounts and all this
stuff.
He's delusional.
He can't admit defeat, defeat.
That could be part of it.
But the other part of it could be maybe Trump
realizes I'm out, but I've got to pay down
some of this debt, let me bamboozle my followers
into donating money, and I'll take half of
it and just use it to pay down debt.
It's probably a combination of both, but the
grift is real and there is always one more
grift.
A we have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the polls.
Now, I'm still putting together the final
data, but again, there is this idea.
The polls totally failed.
The reality once again, is that looking at
averages of polls, the polls were about as
accurate as they always are.
You just have to understand polling to do
it.
I will not be issuing a defense of the polling
industry by any means, but I will be explaining
the data to you.
And we're going to talk about that on today's
bonus show.
Number two, we are going to delve deeper into
this idea of Trump doing rallies and rallies
meant to raise money and fire people up for
his legal challenges to the election results.
Is he really going to do it?
What would be the effect?
Does he have any reason not to do it at this
point in time?
That will be a topic on today's bonus show.
And we will also talk about the movement of
the stock market since it became clear that
Joe Biden would be president of the United
States.
And there's actually people on the left that
are angry.
So my view on this is we have a stock market
and we have GDP and we have employment and
unemployment numbers and we have job creation
and we have consumer confidence given that
these things exist.
And altogether they do tie to how well the
economy is doing.
I want someone in office who's going to see
the better numbers.
And historically, it's been Democrats.
There are also people on the left who say,
see, the fact that the stock market does better
under Democrats is evidence that Democrats
are even worse corporatists than Republicans
and Democrats are actually bad.
Now, of course, that's extremely myopic because
all economic indicators do better under Democratic
presidents.
So I want to talk about that on the bonus
show as well.
If you have not yet heard the bonus show or
watched the bonus show, I know we have a lot
of new viewers and listeners that are here
because of the explosive growth of the show
over the last 10 days.
The bonus show is a daily extra show for our
members and patrons.
Producer Pat, the producer of the show, joins
me on the bonus show.
I would love for you to join me as well.
Two ways to do it.
Go to join Pakman Dotcom and grab a membership.
We have a new coupon code, Fresh Start.
Why do we have a new coupon code, the previous
coupon code related to the 2020 election?
That election is done.
We now are actually trying to take a fresh
start here in the United States with Joe Biden
and maybe with the Democratic Senate, depending
on what happens in Georgia.
So the coupon code, fresh start, massive discount.
I won't even tell you how big of a discount
it is because I'll have my lawyers beating
down the doors telling me, no, it's too big
of a discount, but sign up at Join Pakman
Dotcom or make a pledge at Patreon Dotcom
Slash David Pakman show and join me today
on the bonus show.
We'll talk stocks and markets will talk.
Trump rallies, we'll talk polling.
Pat actually has some interesting stories
from the weekend as well.
He made a bunch of crank calls.
Some call them phony phone calls to the Trump
voter fraud line.
And he will tell us about it and actually
have a lot more
to discuss related
to that.
I will see you then.